This video is sponsored by no one happy holidays from Vsauce, too.
The sauce, Kevin here, and I've combined one of the Leah's games.
Anyone can play with one of the stupidest,
which is why I we'll need to complete morons to play it.
Thomas Edison and Nicola Tesla. Okay.
They're actually two of the most legendary geniuses of all time,
but their rivalry was serious,
especially over Tesla's alternating current AC electricity,
and Edison's direct current DC,
which we now call the war of the currents,
throwing decades of personal disputes. And they've got a score to settle.
Their balloon avatars will fight to the death with the help of a
toy revolver and a single needle dart.
There'll be playing a form of Russian roulette. Watch my surviving,
the deadliest game video for the math on the original and the stupidest
game humans have played is probably the classic duel where two people
just stand there and shoot at each other on guard
that's that's fencing, but you know what I mean?
These two Titans of the electron are gunna duel with this
one gun Russian roulette style. Okay. The game is simple.
Play your a modes. The cartridge spins the cylinder and shoots it.
Player B. He's so close that it's impossible to miss.
The gun will either fire and he'll win or not.
If it doesn't fire,
he hands the gun to play or B who then spins the cylinder again,
and then shoots. I play her a Ben.
Eventually it goes on until one of them is crowned the emperor of
electricity. First off, don't try this actual game, please,
especially because I'll show you exactly how to try this actual game
without trying this actual game anyway, for now,
what we really want to know is who's more likely to win Edison or
Tesla. Someone's got to go first.
So I'll use an unbiased coin flip to determine the order heads
for Edison tales for Tesla. Here we go.
Heads for Edison, Harrison.
All right, here we go. First shot for Edison to Tesla
who wait to figure out whether there's an advantage to going first.
We can just map out the scenarios in which Edison wins.
We don't even need numbers. Sorry,
numbers let's use E for when the gunfire is for Edison and an X.
When the gun does not fire,
here's a map of all the possible Edison victories.
This goes on until the gun ease can only fall
on the odd rounds because Edison went first and that's really the
difference here.
Edison and Tesla have the same chance of winning every round one out of
six,
but Edison can win on the very first round before Tesla even gets a
turn. That's a major advantage,
but how much and how has this first round
advantage?
Because one of the biggest games in the world to literally change its rules,
we'll get to that later for now. It's time.
Edison's first shot Erie spin the old revolver.
Here we go.
Tesla survives. Okay. Where are we? Let's think about this.
Ability of Edison firing the gun is one over six from the first round,
plus the probability of success in subsequent rounds.
And this goes on and on.
As long as Edison and Tesla keep missing spoiler,
the total probability of the gun firing for Edison comes out to six,
over 11 or 0.5, four or five, four repeating.
So Edison's got a 54.5% chance of winning
this dual, which means Tesla.
Tesla is at just 45.5%.
That's a 9% disadvantage for Tesla.
Even in this balloon rivalry,
the deck is stacked in favor of Edison.
You can calculate manually how many trigger poles are in the average game of
idiots, Russian roulette, but Paul J napkins,
Monte Carlo simulations of 10,000 trials confirmed that.
It's about six here's.
What's interesting about two thirds of those games are over in the first six
rounds. There's a long tail with some games going 20 or 30 rounds,
but it's generally a quick game. So Edison getting that first shot.
Really matters. Wait, you can.
Actually run Russian roulette,
simulations yourself without a computer program or anything more dangerous.
You've got a random number generator in your pocket.
Open the stopwatch, divide a second into six,
0.01 to 0.17 corresponds to the gun firing
0.18 to 0.00 means it doesn't fire.
Start the stopwatch, close your eyes and stop it.
The decimal value of the seconds is a random firing simulator that you can
use to map out Russian roulette safely.
But now it's time to get back to our game.
And it's time for Teslas revanche here we go.
Hold on.
If Tesla going second means that he's at such a disadvantage.
How can we make the game more fair?
We can't just play 1000 times alternating who gets to go first?
So that Pantages even out someone's getting popped.
We get one shot at this.
So let's just change the rules to compensate for giving Edison.
The first shot new game.
If Edison's gun doesn't fire in round one,
Tesla gets two shots. If neither of Tesla's shots,
fire Edison gets three shots. This goes on until the gun fires.
Does that actually make the game more fared is giving Tesla an additional shot
after round one enough to make up for his disadvantage
new map. Okay. There's the map of our new version of the game.
And we can do the same sort of calculation as before,
but the probability of Edison's gun firing is now
that with an exponent corresponding to each of Edison's
rounds,
the alternating expanding rounds model reduces Edison's chance of winning all
the way down to about 52.4%.
That's two points lower for Edison and two points higher for all Tesla
here. Who's now sitting at 47.6%. It's better.
It's not great, but it's better.
We can keep tweaking the rules. We can keep running the math,
but the most critical part of the deadliest dumbest game might not be
how it's played.
But actually that coin flip that determines who goes
first, which is what the national football league.
One of the most popular sports leagues in the world realized when it changed its
sudden death overtime rules in 2010,
the team who got the ball first won the game.
So often that not winning the coin toss to determine who played on offense.
First meant you lose the game nearly three out of five
times, but check this out. Look what I found. You're not going to believe this.
And if you do, I won't believe you. All right. Look,
when the NFL used sudden death overtime rules coin flip winners won
52% of the time coin flip losers,
one 43.4% of the time.
The other 4.6% were ties. If we evenly distributed,
those ties as wins.
That's 54.3% to the coin flip winner and
45.7% for the loser sound
familiar. Those are almost the exact same odds of our original Edison,
Tesla, dual game. Look at that. Look at it.
Maybe that's why they called this sudden death settle his dual
once. And for all, here we go. Okay. So using our new game rules,
Tesla actually gets another shot. All right, shot number two for Tesla.
Here we go.
Innocent.
Oh, Anniston survives. Now it,
those back to Edison's turn. That's two misses for Tesla. Here we go.
Now Edison gets three shots. Say or prayer's Tesla.
You're going to need.
Them.
Oh, survives once again. Okay.
Two more shots for Edison.
[Inaudible].
That's another one. All right. One more for Edison.
And then it's going back to Tesla. Here we are.
Oh.
He made it through round two.
Now Tesla gets four tries Edison.
You really should have done it that time. Four shots for Tesla shot him.
Ooh.
Ooh, shot. Number one, survived
shot. Number two, shot. Number two. This game.
Maybe we'll make it to a 30 rounds. Here we go. Spinning shot.
Number three for Tesla.
Number three, the game continues shot. Number four,
chance. Number four. You think one of these four would be in.
That's fine.
I can't believe it. I can't believe it for down. Now.
It goes to five shots for Edison shot.
Number one, Radison.
All right. The game continues. The game continues shot. Number two.
You think it's one of these? It would be it not so not.
So I'm totally randomizing this folks. No, no funny games here.
Shot number three.
[Inaudible].
No, I am so sorry. I am sorry.
You have been reduced to this.
This is all that's left of Nikola Tesla. Just to address it up.
Pringles can cause all we have left. Well, there you go.
Edison wins. The numbers worked.
I've got nothing more to say other than, and as always.
Thanks for watching.
[inaudible].